one of the young leaders was talking to
me about
climate mental health I said tell me
what's going on with your peers climate
Mental Health
all right Kamala is worried the vice
president our climate mental health is
an issue but here's a more ridiculous
take on climate change ready the LA
Times thinks driving can be
racist in a brand new op-ed and here's
what they're basing it on how white and
affluent drivers are polluting the air
breathed by LA's people of color the
author cites a study claiming that white
commuters who drive more spread
pollution into lower income
neighborhoods occupied by people of
color with that premise let's begin with
Harold Ford I apologize I must have been
driven in L.A and I didn't know I was
driving racistly so I throw myself on
the mercy of you Harold this is absurd
um I'm one who believes that when race
is an issue we ought to point it out
absolutely and we ought to we ought to
address it head on uh I don't under I
don't understand I mean I did read this
I'm sorry and I can't for the life of me
understand why you know you would
belittle this issue both issues by
invoking racism we have a climate change
issue in our country we can disagree on
the severity of it we can also have a
debate and we should a robust debate
about what we should do to to help
people breathe easier to help ensure
that we're able to compete on a global
stage with all of the renewable energies
and renewable energy sources that we
produce but when we invoke this this
this creates a whole other line of
consternation and conversation that's
unnecessary we should stick to the facts
about climate change and how and what we
can be doing as a nation to ensure that
oil and gas we can do it as clean as
possible and that we're able to
transition to a renewable energy economy
over the next 10 20 30 years for a
country of all Races and genders Dana
you had something to add here well
pollution and smog aren't are different
it's different from global warming and
greenhouse gas emissions first of all so
the other thing is the vast majority of
people buying these very expensive
electric vehicles that have fewer
emissions are white people
and that that's one of the ways that the
administration targeted the subsidies
and that's just the way it is because
those people have I guess more money
they want to spend it on electric
vehicles and they know that Uncle Sam
will help out which means that actually
that actually is something I would
complain about if I were in a minority
Community why are you giving subsidies
to rich white people for electric
vehicles right that doesn't make any
sense they can afford it you don't need
to do that and take our taxpayer dollars
in order to do it also when you talk
about climate change there's a growing
group of Republicans who are willing to
engage on this issue and every time they
try the Democrats move the goal post say
some crazy stuff and it prevents any
real good conversations from happening
Jesse you agree
Dana is defending white people uh sure
why not
listen the Chinese are the ones that are
polluting everybody yeah they're they're
they're the most racist right
statistically right Brian and it's not
about race it's about class people with
the money are the ones that design these
highways to go through poor
neighborhoods because they can't put up
a big enough fight because I don't have
the lawyers that's what it has to do
with Kamala is saying there's a lot of
climate anxiety because we've been
forcing kids to stay inside their rooms
and look at phones for six years
if you take an animal out of the wild
Brian and put him into a zoo and then
release him back in the wild the animal
is going to die that's what we're doing
with kids we're taking them out of
normal society putting them in a dark
room alone with a screen and then
expecting them to do things I can't
handle it combo did come out and say
that she does talk to kids and they're
so worried about global warming they
don't want to have kids I do think that
actually it's a story and that's there's
legitimacy behind it well we went
through we went through a nuclear war
women we have started a nuclear war for
40 years but kids still had kids here's
the bottom line I want to commend Kamala
for the impactful groundbreaking work
that the woman does every day first of
all all this nonsense even Twitter says
that the warning label on this claim
about people in the inner city being
affected is false Boeing says it's false
everyone says it's false and by the way
electric vehicles still produce harmful
air pollution via get this dust from the
brake pads and toxic chemicals in the
tires so
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else